here to talk about those surprising
unemployment numbers in the state of the
nation's economy cbs news senior
business analyst jill schlesinger jill
good morning let's start with just the
overall economy what does this report
tell us about where we are now
well as you heard 235 000 that's about a
third of what we were expecting but
maybe more importantly a real
deceleration from the previous two
months previous two months we had about
a million jobs added each of those
months 235 is also a big deceleration
from the monthly average this year we're
averaging
586 000 jobs every month throughout the
year so far so this is a little bit of a
warning sign just remember it's one
report it will get revised twice the
president is right there has been great
progress 17 million jobs added since we
hit those lows back in april of 2020 but
it leaves more than five million fewer
positions so we do have a ways to go so
we saw a boom in the leisure and
hospitality sector over the last few
months but this report showed a dip so a
substantial dip why that specific sector
well that has really been the sharp tip
of the recovery process we know leisure
and hospitality just took a beating amid
covid we now have recovered about 90 of
the jobs in leisure and hospitality but
economists are worried because with this
slowdown again we've been averaging 350
000 jobs a month in this one sector now
we had basically flat hiring last month
that really does tell you the power of
this surging virus with the variant on
the good side of this there are other
industries that seem to be shielded from
the spread of the variant and
professional and business services
continue to show very good progress
transportation and warehousing adding
jobs and manufacturing adding jobs so
those are not particularly impacted so
far but again we are watching leisure
and hospitality closer we still have 10
fewer jobs in that one sector
jill a lot of people look at the fed for
mortgages borrowing investing money
what's going to happen where do you
think the fed goes with interest rates
in the near term here
this is a really tough situation for the
federal reserve because we've been
talking about the fact that prices have
been rising amid covid due to various
shortages and the thought was that with
prices rising and the job landscape and
improving dramatically the fed could
ease off of some of the policies they're
still buying bonds every single month
interest rates are still at all-time
lows at zero percent now what happens
next is the fed watches these numbers
very closely economists believe that
they're probably not going to do
anything at the meeting this month maybe
not even for the rest of this year but
again this is one report i do want to
put that as a caveat because things
could pick up presuming the surge were
to calm down at this point well chill
everybody all eyes are on this so we
thank you for watching